Michael Peretti author of the
assassination of Julius Caesar this is
what book for you my 17th book why on
the subject of the assassination of
Julius Caesar I was doing some reading
in Greek philosophy and Greek political
theory I'm a political scientist by
training and I started getting
interested in the Romans and I thought
well they could never be as interesting
as the Greeks but politically
politically they certainly are and the
the late Republic was especially
interesting time lots of intrigues lot
of struggles going on interesting
personalities emerging some giant
figures like Caesar Cicero the Gracchi
and it was a compelling story and then I
I also thought the way it was told
mostly was was wasn't the whole story
and I wanted to give a different
interpretation cuz I think the evidence
suggested that I want to go to chapter 9
which is the assassination and have you
just tell that story then we'll go back
and pick up on the whole dates and
everything what were the circumstances
in which Julius Caesar was assassinated
he was at the height of his power he had
just won a civil war against Pompey in
the aristocratic army he was putting in
a lot of popular reforms a lot of the
aristocrats who had sided with Pompey he
brought them back forgave them gave them
back their estates and their property
and tried to co-opt them bring them into
his in fact gave them some very choice
appointments but they really felt he was
taking over the Republic they were
unhappy with all these reforms that he
was doing and so they got together the
best we know it was Casius who enlisted
his close friend and relative Brutus and
they were about oh about 40 or so people
in on the plot and they did a minute in
the Senate and then the Senate in the
Senate here in the Senate gathering in
Rome in in Rome you know is just the
Pompeii that's just south of Rome
no no no Pompeii is that's the name of a
city but Pompeii was the name of a man
who was a general so you're talking
about the man Pompeii in this case yes
right Pompeii was now dead by this time
and Caesar was pretty much the man in
control all right the Senate in Rome how
many would have been in the Senate and
what day what year it was in 44 BC it
really marked the end Caesars death
marked the end of a 500 year Republic
after he died civil war broke out
Augustus took over and he became the
first emperor and you had an emperor
system going after that but from how
about 500 something BC to 44 BC Rome was
a republic in development I mean the
people fought for tribal assembly they
fought for some land redistribution the
Senate's powers were very great and then
they receded and then they were great
again there was a period of Sulis
dictatorship where he restored all the
powers to the Senate so it was an act of
500 years of all kinds of struggle that
went on how many senators were there 600
they all there that day
probably not know mmm and and of course
the great majority of them didn't know
what was going to happen Caesar came in
how old was he by the way he was 56 um
he came in a group of senators came up
to him in an apparently friendly way one
of them was petitioning for the return
of his brother from exile and C's had
waved him away and say this is no time
to talk about that and that particular
senator pulled his toga his robe off his
shoulder which was the sign and they all
took out their daggers and they went at
him and he he suffered 23 stab wounds
and dropped dropped and and bled to
death now you have a footnote your first
footnote in that chapter
we have no surviving eyewitness reports
of Caesars assassin
that's correct what does that mean just
that time and the and the church when it
came in really destroyed most of the
records of pagan Rome and so we have
very little of any of that but what we
do have is we have a lot of what what
are called
original sources that is Plutarch Appian
do Cassius who wrote a hundred two
hundred years later but they had access
to certain primary sources and they do
mention some of them there was a fairly
good eyewitness account that Plutarch
relied upon what do you know about
Julius Caesar is a person how big was he
how big a mean and physically physically
he was a tall man very attractive he
came from a very well placed patrician
family but he sided with the popular
party he wanted reforms he felt Rome
needed reforms for Rome to survive those
who had a lot had to give a little and
he wanted to rein in the self enriching
class he pushed for land distribution
rent controls debt cancellation luxury
taxes on the very rich these were the
things that they really disliked about
him he encouraged the development of
guilds and unions they weren't called
unions and called guilds of the common
people so that they could have a
presence he bypassed the Senate when he
when he came back and took over the
government he bypassed the Senate and he
he sent he sent things through the
tribal assemblies through the the the
the forum and the assemblies so that the
common is voted on things what was his
title his title by this time was Emperor
to perpetual excuse my Latin but and
literally Emperor for life
how did he get that job oh the word
emperor hadn't had the same commander it
would have meant commander well when he
when he came back from Gaul the
aristocratic party wanted him to
surrender his army and to appear and
present himself he knew he'd be finished
if he did that he called for an alliance
a mutual disarming of him of his group
and the aristocrats who met who now had
wooed Pompey with him and and let the
peat as he said let the people at the
Senate and the people of Rome through
their assemblies rule Rome and we'll
have no armies they they did not they
really pushed for a one-sided the the
ultra the ultra oligarchic group did the
Senate actually agreed to that plan that
was a perfectly nice plan with disarmed
Pompey will disarm Caesar won't have to
worry about either of them and we will
stay in the saddle the the more
conservative aristocratic group
conservative might not be the word
reaction or they were really looking to
go back to a pre Constitution that was
200 years before they didn't want that
they wanted the whole thing and they
would not compromise with Caesar in any
way and they encouraged Pompey to raise
an army and they and they demanded that
Caesar disband his army and come back
unarmed so he did not hit coming back I
should explain from Gaul he was where is
Goll Goll is is what is now France
France and other parts of German he also
invaded and took over he came back and
and this is when he made that momentous
decision to cross the Rubicon the
Rubicon was a small River in northern
Italy when you cross it you're in
Italian territory
and if you come back with an army onto
into Italian territory without
permission of the government you've
committed an act of treason
you've committed it I mean it's it's
civil war and and today in our language
we still have that expression crossing
the Rubicon which means a momentous
decision
an irrevocable decision and as he came
down the peninsula the Italian cities
opened their gates to him the town's
welcomed him they saw him as somebody
who was more or less on their side and
and they land and the the oligarchic the
elite aristocratic party realizing they
couldn't hold Rome against him went to
Greece where they felt they had stronger
support and eventually Caesar took his
army to Greece and beat Pompey and won
the civil war and came back and there he
was at the height of his power how old
was he when he was the height of his
power when he became Emperor when he
became commander it wasn't it was
Emperor next was that the next day yeah
Augustus took that same turn and well he
called himself the Principate the prime
man the first man first citizen
literally yeah but but he really started
the Emperor's system because Caesar was
still working with the tribal assemblies
and still encouraging the people's
Tribune's the Tribune aides
were the Tribune 8 was a people's
council sort of made up of ten Tribune's
who had some remarkable powers for that
day they could even veto certain Senate
acts for instance and they could
initiate legislation with the Assemblies
ins in the sense they were quite a
democratic group how old was he then
when he became commander I was safe in
his 54th year safe from 46 by 46 he was
he was he was the top man so he was only
on top not only but he was on top for 10
years uh oh no I mean 46 BC no he's on
top just for a few years for a couple a
year for a few years but through those
years even before he had pushed for a
variety of reforms and when he was
constantly it reformed for those
watching her saying about now why do I
want to know this you know all these
names and references the part of the
time that I don't even care about what
would you say as a political scientist I
think it's a very fascinating period I
thought the I mean I didn't do justice
to a description of the assassination
it's
just intrigues even more fascinating
than the assassination is the aftermath
the way forces were beginning to jockey
and trying to figure out what was coming
next nobody realized the Republic was
finished you know the way people fought
for political power the issues of the
day of the few wanting at all in the
many wanting wanting something back
those kind of issues the it was very
fascinating very relevant time in a way
how many times did Caesar Mary season
had three wives who were they the first
one was a young one are you gonna you're
gonna put me on the spot to remember
their names and I can't even remember a
girlfriend's name something uh
Calpurnia was the last wife the one who
begged him not to go to the Senate house
cuz she had what today we would call a
precognitive dream where she visualized
Caesar covered in blood and she felt
this was a bad something terrible was
going to happen the the first his first
wife he loved her dearly she died I
think in childbirth the second wife he
had to he divorced in Oh sixty sometime
or sixty or 59 BC around there because
she had been implicated in an affair
with Claudius who was a good political
ally of his quite a while fellow who
called for the freeing of slaves and was
organizing the poor and doing all sorts
of all sorts of admirable things from
the point of view of the Reformers hated
by the aristocrats and hated by most of
the historians too and Claudius dressed
up as a woman and worked his way into
the Virgin the inner sanctum there so it
was some kind of a religious place where
only the women went to carry on an
affair with Caesars wife who herself
certainly wasn't a virgin I don't quite
exactly what she was doing she wasn't
one of the vestal virgins but she was
there and so where does that phrase
purest Caesar's wife come it's it's a
that's true it's it's see it's only half
the phrase it really should be one must
be if you're Caesar's wife you must be
pure government and his statement was
I'm divorcing her he he maintained no no
she had no affair with Claudius but
Caesar's wife must be above suspicion
so Caesar's wife must be pure doesn't
mean Caesar's wife was pure yeah it's a
Mis phrasing in a way how many children
did you don't want anybody who was as
pure as Caesar's wife I don't mean how
many children are there I don't think
they had any he had he he had one child
with he never really had an heir he had
one child with Cleopatra a son who
Augustus made sure to kill didn't want
any direct heirs of Caesars around okay
who was Augustus
Augustus was Caesar's nephew and
Augustus was a rather remarkable maybe
not that admirable but quite remarkable
individual after Caesars death Augustus
came forward took command of an army at
the age of 19 led this army got into the
intrigues
fighting first sided with the Senate
oligarchy then switched and made an
alliance with Mark Antony and Lupita's
Lupita's with Caesars head of cavalry
and Antony was a longtime associate and
ally of Caesars the three of them formed
a tran Britt and fought back and
defeated the Senate oligarchs and took
over and then Lapidus was isolated and
kicked out of the triumvirate and then
Antony and and Augustus divided up the
Roman Empire with Augustus getting Rome
and the western portion Spain and Gaul
in places and Antony getting Greece and
the
in Egypt and then there was a final
battle in which in which Augustus
defeated Antony the famous Antony and
Cleopatra Antony was living with
Cleopatra at the time and Augustus then
became emperor but you say that he
called himself Augustus Caesar that a
lot of Emperor's after that used the
name Caesar right Caesar became a title
almost in fact it comes right down to
our day in Latin is his name is Julius
Kaiser and Kaiser is a term that was
used by the German nobility too so they
picked up on it maybe it's a holdover
from the Holy Roman Empire I don't know
exactly after Julius Caesar was
assassinated Augustus Caesar was in
power for how long his name by the way
originally was Octavian Octavius and and
then the Senate decided to give him the
title of Augustus and he took that and
he also took the title of Caesar with
him he ruled for something like forty
seven years or so quite a bit because he
came in rather young I mean there were a
number of years of of civil war and then
he went he until he emerged supreme and
then he died and I think was about 14 or
17 AD go back to the actual
assassination yeah Julius Caesar had no
idea that this was gonna happen oh he
had his suspicions he knew there had
been conspirators and conspiracies
around but he said you cannot live under
guard all the time to live under garters
to live perpetually in fear how do we
know or how do you know that there were
actually 23 stabbings that's what's
reported whether it's true or not I
don't know I mean who actually did the
counting in that tumultuous time he had
multiple he did die from multiple wounds
though they were quite a number of
people putting a dagger in him did he
die right away
there are there are accounts which say
yeah that two or three of these were
were pretty much fatal in a matter of
minutes and he collapsed and he bled he
was he was pretty much and they kept
going at him even when he was down so
there was a little doubt that he he had
given the absence of modern emergency
rooms and all that he was gone how many
big names from that period stabbed him
really the only two that we know are
Casius and Brutus would be the big names
you say that and Decimus Brutus also see
the number of people that stabbed him he
had that seizure had helped yes yes
they're all in there I mentioned them
all but but yeah well they weren't they
they weren't interested in I mean he
gave them back as I say their estates he
gave them some choice appointments but
this was not this was not what they
wanted Rome was what how big was it how
many people there in those days Rome was
about half a million was it you say it
was it a republic it was still a
republic yes it was a republic it had
these Assemblies that had this people's
Tribune eight it had the Senate the
Senate was not elected by anybody well
actually it that's not true anybody it's
a strange aristocracy because it's it
was somewhat hereditary but it also was
electoral that is the way your family
became an aristocratic family was if you
had someone in your lineage who had been
elected to the highest office which was
consul Roman consul there were two
consuls elected every year and and
usually they were elected from the
families that already were aristocratic
families
how did Rome fit into Italy Rome by this
time by the late Republic dominated all
of Italy and there were struggles going
on Caesar was one of them by people who
wanted to extend citizenship beyond Rome
to much of Italy to our the other
provinces of Italy so that they would
not be subjects there would be citizens
what what was define a republic
in those days a republic república ruled
by the public which means that there's
popular rule that the people are to some
degree the rulers of the country what
was the forum the forum wasn't was this
open-air area where people gathered to
debate issues the actual voting didn't
take place there it was a bit off some
places where they would pass through and
and register their votes but the forum
was this great gathering place where
debates took place well consuls came
down
Cicero spoke in the forum Caesar spoke
in the forum it must have been quite a
remarkable time located where in Rome
well I visited it the photo Romano and I
don't know rather central is rather
there's a Colosseum right near the
Colosseum just down from the capital
line he'll you have the forum here and
you have the capital line he'll just 100
meters up there and and up on this hill
you have the Senate House in fact
visiting Rome I had to rewrite I was in
the middle of writing the book I had to
rewrite up or add a little something
because I suddenly occurred to me that
when Brutus and Kassius and these people
after they had killed Caesar and they
had gathered up on the capital line Hill
I thought it was a different part of
town from the forum a safe distance but
it was only about a hundred meters they
could hear the angry shouts of the
crowds and you know avenge Caesar killed
the assassins and that sort of thing and
this was getting them rather nervous
there was quite a quite a few days of
struggle that went on there was a there
was a there were a lot of killings on
both sides what was the reaction on the
part of the people when Julius Caesar
was assassinated well that's what I'm
just describing anger desire for revenge
but what did they do what I mean by the
reaction is what did they do about it
there were riots there were killings of
people who they suspected and and the
and others were killed that they killed
people who were actually part of the
assassin group as far as we know yes
they may have even killed some others by
mistake
people who weren't associated with the
assassination they went after very rich
appearing people at times they
themselves were killed in some
substantial numbers because the the
assassins were not idle during this they
mobilized their own death squads and
their own gangs and cummin came down so
there were a lot of just pitched battles
in the streets going on but within a few
days decima Brutus said we all better
clear out of Italy this is just too hot
and if it cools then we can come back if
it doesn't cool down then we're gonna
have to raise an army and fight our way
back and that's exactly what happened
how did you get started in this business
historian political scientists I have a
PhD from Yale and political science I'm
a recovering academic I call myself I've
taught at a number of universities but
in the last 15 years or the world and
occasional guest a guest teaching
position but I've been devoting myself
full-time to writing and lecturing where
did you teach I've taught at State
University of New York at Sarah Lawrence
College City University of New York
Brooklyn College a year a year at
Cornell where did you get your
undergraduate degree my undergraduate
degree was from City College of New York
my MA was from Brown University and my
PhD was from Yale and what were all
those in political science where's your
hometown originally I'm originally from
New York you probably can hear it from
either city New York City yeah Manhattan
in Manhattan that's right what was your
family like my family was a blue-collar
italian-american family my grandparents
were immigrants and very hardworking
people you know
what did your father and mother do for a
living my mother worked in a dress shop
and my father worked well he yeah we had
a little Italian bakery which he
inherited from his uncle for a while
I've written stories about that and and
he also for a while was a taxi driver
you don't know this but for several
years some of our cars on our Colin
shows here have called up and admonished
me or us they want to know who this
person is in this background no no
they've said you never have on this
network howard zinn
you never have on this network Noam
Chomsky and you never have on this
network michael Parenti they always put
those three names together oh that's
nice the other two have been on this is
your first time that I know have you
been on right why did they for years
they have linked the three of you
together well we all we all write a lot
of critical things about the
powers-that-be we have a dissident
viewpoint that is not usually heard on
the mainstream media and and so I guess
they feel and we all have a readership a
fairly substantial readership and such a
lot of blood it seems to be a lot of
interest in my my work and certainly Xin
and Chomsky a great deal of interest and
how has the media treated you over the
years very sparingly I can say I can I
may I can get a lot of radio appearances
with small community stations I've been
on a few Network debates on crossfire
once twice and crossfire but it wasn't a
particularly pleasant experience you
have one person screaming here another
screaming here and and you're supposed
to just get your one sentence in and it
it wasn't if you want to stop and try to
explain something in any way it's not
very easy do you think there's a reason
why you haven't appeared in these
networks
yeah I think it's a political thing I
think the the the big corporations are
very right-wing I wouldn't call him
conservative I don't think I don't think
the president Administration is
conserved consider conservative as
someone who doesn't want to change he
doesn't want to yield any of his
privileges he wants to keep every
advantage he has and so forth but what
we're getting is really reactionary a
rollback of of all the gains made from
the New Deal on and the people who
dominate the talk shows the airwaves are
these shock jocks these right-wing guys
who seem to specialize in in bruising
and declaiming and slinging labels
around so I don't think we get a kind of
dialogue that really needs to be any
reason why this is the case you think
it's because who owns the media and who
pays for the advertising and the like
you're 17 books yes give us an idea of
what kind of books they've been oh
they're great books it's a variety of
books perhaps my most successful book is
democracy for the few which is in its
seventh edition that's used as a
textbook in in various schools at time
to time and that's that's a book that
that that takes a critical perspective
of the American political system and and
argues for more democracy more reforms
and that sort of thing your first book
is listed as the anti-communist impulse
1969 right that was a book that was
critical of of the ID that
anti-communism should be the end all of
our foreign policy and that policy
should be driven preoccupation me by
anti-communism power in the powerless 78
I'm just jumping around here power and
the powerless was a book used by
sociologists mostly that was a
structural analysis of the structures of
institutions in society and how power
tends to gravitate to the top and why
and and the like inventing reality the
politics of news media 1986 1993 correct
written two years before Chomsky's
manufacturing consent I should say that
was a critic of the distortions in the
media and that one got reviewed in the
New York Times in your Washington Post
and I did get on one or two shows with
that book how do you know I'm Chomsky
get along are you
pals nah not particularly pals I mean I
know him I have I have disagreements I
have a couple things I disagree with
with him tell us what you disagree with
him well I I disagree with him on on
Yugoslavia i I think we should have left
Yugoslavia alone and I think Clinton's
policy was wrong and I dislike the
bombing of Yugoslavia no and and he
seemed to have supported all the
criticism that's that would be
particular issue is nothing that
vehement Chomsky we've correspondent
where we're we're not personal friends
cuz I just don't have me to know him
personally I do know Howard personally
he's a friend and endorses this book
yeah cause it provocative and eloquent
there you go yes I was on a website and
one of the website that I was on I can't
remember the name of it they defined you
they liked you and they defined you as a
Marxist is it fair well what I don't
like about the term is I write about all
sorts of things that Marx you know
that's what somebody said about
inventing reality is this a Marxist
analysis of the media the eagerness to
label something puts a closure on on
thought and I said well you know I don't
know what Karl Marx had to say about us
corporate media in the 20th century in
fact he didn't have a word to say but
he's been dead for hundred years so I
came to these things on my own so I
don't use
I don't use labels in that sort so
wouldn't it make you happy if you read
that website when you saw that label it
wouldn't make me unhappy either because
there's a lot in Marxism that makes a
sense there there are some things that
need really redoing in Marxism very
serious redoing that's another whole
show if you want you talked about in
this book Julius Caesar about historians
yes and and as it's safe to say you
don't like a lot of historians I mean I
don't mean personally but you a lot of
the you don't think their history is
very accurate yeah well my writing of
history I wrote an earlier book to call
history as mystery it just increased my
love and respect for history but my
respect for historians kind of went down
a bit they just repeat each other's
facile formula statements they they seem
to uncritically share the elite elitist
viewpoint of of that day of the
historians of that day and uncritically
share it you know and so so I do the
book is written the two levels one is
the events themselves and all that and
all and then how those events have been
portrayed and how you might question
that Julius Caesar a great man in your
opinion he's not my hero my hero is the
people of Rome because I thought he was
a pretty good I thought he was very good
as a reformer in Rome not at all I did
not at all like him for what he did in
Gaul conquering Gaul and subjecting
these people what what did most
historians today say about Caesar
most of them I think share Cicero's view
which is that Caesar was a usurper a
power grabber he endangered the Republic
he violated the Constitution and that's
why they killed him and I'm arguing no
they killed him they killed him because
he was a reformer when sulla came in in
80
excuse me 80 to 280 BC
mmm he killed people he murdered 50
senators because they weren't
conservative enough hee hee hee murdered
about a thousand equestrians including
many from very well-to-do families
because one nice thing about killing
well-to-do people is you take over their
estates and that becomes your you know
that becomes your pop out of your own
fortune he did all these things and what
is Cicero say about sulla he says on the
whole and admirable accomplishment
although there was a lack of moderation
in certain instances so whose Cicero
Cicero is the hero of most historians
he's the guy who's written an any number
of books about Rome and Rome theory he's
written a book called de república lived
when at the same time as Caesar he was a
contemporary of Caesars and what are you
saying Cicero Cicero was a to face he
would fawn up to Caesar and say we adore
you Caesar we will defend you with our
lives no I mean while he was
he was delighted with the assassination
when it took place he was a an AR evaced
in a way he he didn't come from humble
origins he came from a very wealthy
family an equestrian family but he had
no no other member of his family had
ever been elected to the Senate so he
was a new man as was called and he was a
real go-getter and he his goal was to be
able to serve the oligarchic faction the
the the elite oligarchs and and and
that's what he did an oligarchy again is
what the aristocratic group the group
that really did not want to share power
the group that really opposed land
reform and opposed all the reforms and
really perpetrated a string of
assassinations the point we haven't made
is you know all these reformers
beginning in 133 BC with Tiberius
Gracchus
the Gracchi brothers who probably the
most famous other than C
Tiberius Gracchus his his brother in 122
Gaius Krakus and then you had Drusus
flaccus rufus sarted Sartain Aeneas
there was any a Claudius all of them
were assassinated every single one of
these people were assassinated who took
the side of the ordinary people and to
say and an H case you have these
historians saying oh they were
assassinated because they were grabbing
power they were extreme they they
violated the Constitution they were self
aggrandizing there were demagogues and
that's how they and I and I raised
questions about that what strikes me
it's one thing for the ancient
historians to say they were all
themselves aristocrats they all
themselves were slaveholders and all but
when you see latter day modern
historians taking the same line so
calling Collingwood's admonition that
history is seen differently in different
epoch that Augustine saw it through the
eyes of an early Christian and team on
sword is a 17th century Frenchman and
given as an 18th century Englishman in
Monson as a 19th century German well
it's really not true they all when I
looked at it well that sounds very nice
but as an insight into historiography
but in fact they all mouthed and repeat
Cicero's line they all accept the latest
repressive elitist line which is that
all these various reformers were bad
fellows and demagogues and everything
and I thought they were fighting for
some pretty decent things even the grain
dole which went to the poor let me say
that these ad hominem statements that
these people make about the reformed
leaders through this age also are made
about the people themselves the people
are portrayed if you read Cicero the
people are scum these are the terms use
a starving rabble
I mean he admits they're starving but he
sees this not as symptomatic of their of
their victimization he sees this as as a
deficiency that's personal to them you
know the unwashed well when you call
people unwashed why they unwashed I
don't wash because they don't have any
water they don't have any any cleansers
they don't have access to the bath
houses and so he the oldest pejorative
terms about the people of Rome so
there's an ad hominem attack both on the
leaders the reformed leaders and on the
people themselves and I saw the people I
said well who is this rabble I even have
a quote in there by Marx calling them a
a rabble and a bunch of parasites and
layabouts a lumpin proletariat you know
well who are these people
they were when I looked at him they were
shopkeepers they were carpenters
they were Smith's they were Dockers
Teamsters day jobbers weavers they were
the working proletariat of Rome
construction workers they were people
and what did they do the image you get
of the people of Rome is they spent all
their time waiting for their free bread
their grain dal well that that that
grain dole that dole bread that ration
of bread they got did make a difference
between survival and not survival but
you don't live a life of leisure on a
little raishin of bread you still need
money for fuel you need money for
clothing for for rents the rents were
exorbitant these people worked and what
they did with their lives besides that
they didn't spend it at the circuses and
in the arena all the time I'm sure they
went it was free it's the only only
diversion they had but they also did
things like fight for representative
assemblies for 200 years they fought for
secret ballot and got it they fought for
land redistribution they fought for
protections on Italian industry to
develop domestic industry they fought
for work projects so they could have
jobs
they did some pretty good things in the
people of history should be looked at
little with a little less of an elitist
viewpoint how does that relate to the
United States of America 2003 are there
oligarchs in this country in your
opinion yes I think I think money big
money I don't mean when they say the top
fifth of America the rich what are you
talking about the top fifth of America
you make $100,000 you're in the top 4%
you make 70,000 year in the top fifth
that's not the very the very richer of a
fraction of 1% and they have enormous I
mean they're off the charts they really
go up I do believe that immense
concentration of money does exercise a
disproportionate influence in America
and control of the media the universe of
discourse who gets to run for public
office who who mobilizes the
high-powered lobbyists this is not to
say that it is we live in a pure
oligarchy there are also democratic
elements that people do mobilize
victories can be won and they are won at
times so the struggle continues do you
vote yes I do when I can find somebody
to vote for I vote I didn't vote and I
won't vote for Gray Davis or his
opponent but I don't know I may vote for
a Green Party candidate for governor
where do you live I live in California
and when you look at the structure of
America's democracy right now what do
you think of it the house the Senate
that the courts well I think they have
to be a lot of changes
I think voting has to be better secured
I think people's registration people
should not be disfranchised by being
kept from the polls intimidated asked
for two picture IDs has happened in
Florida
I think there has to be campaign finance
limitations so that people without large
sums of money can get their issues heard
there has to be greater diversity I
think we should get rid of term limits
in California has been a disaster term
limits in the assembly you have people
running assembly totally inexperienced
have no institutional memory and when
when they keep goofing up like this then
who takes over the staff and the
lobbyists nobody elected those people I
think I think we shouldn't be spending
four hundred twenty billion dollars on
military I don't believe we should have
300 military bases all over the world I
don't believe we should be having troops
in Afghanistan and Iraq and killing
people in these various places to make
the world safe for the oil cartels if
the public wanted what you want
why haven't they spoken out why haven't
they voted these folks in office out
well people can be manipulated and
misled if they never even really hear
outside of the story they they're not
going to necessarily push for it our
side and yet it is interesting despite
the bombardment the one-sided
bombardment they are they often are
reluctant they often don't want war once
the war starts then then the president's
approval ratings spike they rally around
the flag and the flag is wrapped around
the president and they say well we got
to support our troops
this happened with the first Gulf War I
mean the polls right up until close to
the time of intervention were very
lukewarm people didn't what do we kind
of send troops off to where Iraq after
the American people hadn't heard of it
and couldn't even find it on the map hmm
but once the war started then everybody
gets rallied so people do get many
people but on that on the base of the
ways you're saying you have not been
fooled with all this I mean you've
figured out in your own mind that the
president is wrong and the
kind of expenditure on militaries wrong
why can't the others figure it out well
I think you need access to an analysis
you need access to information that
normally is not available actually you
can find a lot of it in the mainstream
media but you got to really dig around
on page 22 you know but you figured it
out why haven't the rest of well I'm not
the only one there are a lot of people
who figured out and more and more are
figuring it out I mean look at this war
in Iraq there were millions of people
who figured out that Iraq did not have
weapons of mass destruction that Iraq
wasn't harboring terrorists that Iraq
wasn't a mortal threat to the United
States or any other country that had
been battered for ten years by sanctions
and a war before that and millions and
people demonstrated in Spain with the
wainy of Finland Japan in Tokyo Osaka
Kyoto Indonesia people were
demonstrating Canada I mean name the
country Italy Great Britain On February
15th at 2 million people are the largest
public demonstration in the history of
England people were very strongly
against this war so I wasn't it wasn't
just me with my quirky analysis well I'm
going back to other the book and the
Republic and all that and the
assassination you come to this country
now or it is eight degrees it's a
democracy where they can throw people
out if they don't like them I this
question of do we have a democracy I
don't I heard people say we don't have a
democracy you got a Supreme Court this
and money rules and weather and people
say we do have a democracy I don't think
it's do or don't I think we do have
there are democratic elements in our in
our system
there are democratic forces and those
forces need to be strengthened but go
back to again just take the Iraqi war
for instance members of the Congress and
the Senate voted basically didn't they
or didn't they to give the president the
right to do what he did they voted worse
than that they voted against the
Constitution they gave they voted to
give him the power to declare war
whenever he wants
now the declaration of war is not
something that any one executive should
have power to do that's that's a
monarchy that's the power of
Nikki or king or dictator in a republic
the declaration of war should be done by
the sovereign assembly and they have
they have handed it over they did in
October 2002 and said the president go
on can go out there and and and and
point out any country he wants and say
what we're going to hit them next we're
gonna hit them next but how would you do
it I mean how would you set up your
government any differently to give the
people more power in the circumstances
again I go back to if they didn't want
this couldn't they have well Ange the
Congress well in democracy with a few I
have whole set of reforms had I know
we're going to talk about that way I
would have brought that in Brian but I
think first of all you have to start
electing different people to elect
different people you got to have a
different way of financing and carrying
out elections they should have right to
media we shouldn't have to buy you
shouldn't have to spend millions of
dollars to get on the media the media
are licensed that it's the airwaves the
airwaves are the property of the people
of the United States and and and time
should be given to people you know
candidates of all sorts on the media the
electoral system is part of it the media
itself there should be greater diversity
there should be greater range of
opinions I don't want to I don't want to
silence people who differ from me I
would be very uncomfortable in a system
where I didn't hear anybody different
from me
because I don't know everything there is
you know but I certainly would like to
have a greater range of opinions and
such and not everybody just from A to B
it should really go from A to Z back to
the book may what what can be learned
from reading this book about governments
and about helping this is many years ago
and what are you talking two thousand
years ago at least mm-hmm what can be
learned from reading about Julius Caesar
and his time that would help us better
understand democracy Republic's
government could I read a quote by
Joseph Schumpeter
sure Pompey was Joseph Schumpeter was a
conservative
I missed who was read widely in the
first half of the last century I used to
read him when I was undergraduate in
1950 and in 1919 one of his earliest
writings this is what he wrote he was
describing Roman imperialism the Roman
Empire which the Republic had an empire
at the time I won't read every word
every but as you say and he said Rome
Rome was governed by that policy which
pretends to aspire to peace but
unerringly generates war the policy of
continual preparation for war the policy
of mettlesome interventionism there was
no corner of the known world where some
interest was not alleged to be in danger
or under actual attack if the interests
were not Roman they were those of Rome's
allies and if rome had no allies then
allies would be invented the fight was
always invested with an aura of legality
Rome was always being attacked by evil
minded neighbors always fighting for a
breathing space the whole world was
pervaded by a host of enemies and it was
manifestly Rome's duty to guard against
their indubitably aggressive designs now
does any of that sound familiar to you
at all so he's writing 1919 about Rome
and that could that could be about the
American Empire
we are constantly and I think that's one
of the tricks of ruling groups which is
to distract the people from their
immediate problems and interests by
Alexander Hamilton made this point in
Federalist paper number six he said many
as sovereign has has have any phrase it
has conjured up a crises abroad to
distract the people from their domestic
grievances and I think that's what we
have going today this idea of perpetual
war you know I think war has been very
good for George Bush it's been really
good for him but was it for Bill Clinton
I mean the the intervention that he many
sent Nestle's over there it is today
another things like
yeah he too had to do his blooding and
show he was a tough president in somehow
that shows you really a strong president
I don't I don't know how it helped him
his bombing of Yugoslavia I was in
Yugoslavia among a few weeks after the
bombing and I saw the damage had been
done and and schools that have been hit
and apartment houses
I don't really that doesn't make me feel
proud to be an American when I see
what's done in the name of my country I
was not terribly impressed by Bill
Clinton and what do you think of this
country i I mean this is my country I
think it's a great country it deserves
better leaders and it deserves better
kind of policy we are you know the
council the Council on Foreign Relations
did a national poll maybe it was the Pew
Institute but with the council about how
do people around the world perceive
Americans and the viewpoint was they see
them as arrogant overweening
self-absorbed wanting everything their
way and it's not and and the council
concluded instead of saying well maybe
there's something about our policy we
might want to reexamine they said well
we're not projecting our image
successfully enough I think we I think
Americans are you know there'd I don't I
don't think we are God's gift to
humanity I don't think every nation has
had its nationalists who think that
their country is unique in its history
and every country does have a unique and
fascinating history America does have
when you think what a remarkable history
I mean what a remarkable blend of people
it is unique there's no other place in
the world where you got you know 300
nationalities melting or whatever but
every country has a unique Ireland does
Italy does Spain does Greece does China
does a Japan you can name it they all
have unique histories but every so many
country in 19th century German
nationalists like 50 and troika they've
talked about
Germany that would emerge it would it
would revive it would it would lead all
of humanity to a new epoch it would you
know it there's always this dream that
your country is not only unique but it
will uplift and lead humanity to a
better life it's a nice sentiment does
the Eskie had it about Holy Mother
Russia might seen he had it about Italy
Jefferson had it about America I think
we should be more modest in our our our
agendas and we should really respect
other countries and be not so quick to
use force and violence to solve things I
think that force and violence is not a
mistaken policy I think it's a correct
policy given the interest that George
Bush represents he now has control of
the second-largest oil reserve in the
world 113 billion gallons a very good
quality crude and Halliburton is taking
it over and and fixing up the oil wells
and online and the Iraqis are very
irritated and saying you're supposed to
be helping us and this met then the bush
isn't there to help the Iraqis he's
there to help his his own cartels and to
make sure that Iraq does not take a
self-defining independent path who in
American history either the founding
fathers or somebody do you respect the
most in their thinking the way they
think about how this country ought to be
managed
I thought Lincoln said him many
interesting things that have been
neglected he was an interesting a
Republican president Franklin and
they're they're number my heroes in
American history are the people who
organized the fights for universal
ballad and suffrage for white males to
abolish property rights the people who
are the abolitionists who fought against
slavery the people who fought for the
right for women to have an education and
owned property in and vote so my heroes
of the ordinary people who have fought
throughout history whose names I don't
even know and
you know for the most part who who did
fought for the principle of public
education if they hadn't won that and
and all those things were not given to
us we had to fight against the
plutocracy fight tooth and nail every
single one of those things and and we're
losing a lot of them they've been
fighting to get him get him back and get
us back to 1900 but if it wasn't for
that I wouldn't have been able to go to
a public school you know I came from a
poor family and so those are my heroes
it's not really the big names is your
point of view gaining any any credence
in the country um are you losing
well people I know who are progressives
or even just liberals or even just a
centrist there are many of them are very
depressed they're very unhappy with the
way things have been going in the
country there are some hopeful things I
mean look at the look at the big public
outcry against the FCC where Michael
Powell takes it upon himself to
legislate a change of momentous scope in
ownership of the media can a can a
regulatory agency just set up a new set
of rules that to me is not not by a
three-to-two vote to change the whole
structure of mass media in the country
and look at the immense outcry and push
they woke up Congress on that issue so
you know you do have things happen at
times it's not like the people have
given up I just I I think we should as
Antonio Gramsci said we have to have a a
pessimism of the mind you see how
difficult things are but an optimism of
the will you keep struggling and and and
think you can win some victories and
sometimes we do here's the cover of the
book the assassination of Julius Caesar
a people's history of ancient Rome our
guest Michael Parenti and we thank you
very much thank you